Let's check it out. >> If I had my way, I would disenfranchise
85% of the population instantly. I would Wow,
so cool. Does he realize that like Okay, here's here's the issue.
There is a there's like a catch 22 here. I I should be able to
draw this out, but I can't. I'm just going to try to explain
it. Okay, so obviously on its face. Obviously,
no. Asthma Gold might not go. Asmin Gold might be in the 15%.
Because I think the only way you could break that down is by
taking the 15% of people who contribute the most in taxes. I
think that's the only way you could possibly do this because
otherwise what what incentive is there for any American billionaire
or somebody to even pay taxes in America? Yeah, but hold on.
I think way more than 15% of people are land owners. That is
how they like to break it down though.
Yeah, I think so. Yeah. Terry said maybe land owners only, but
I think there's probably like I don't know 30 40% of people are
land owners, right? And by the way, land owners I think would
even probably just correlate totally to wealth.
So I think I think you'd have to sort it by wealth to not lose
your entire tax base. And then what's why why is anybody paying
taxes unless you have get the guns out? Why is anybody paying
taxes with no ability to vote? And
also if you do that you're eating the bugs. Okay, if you've ever
thought like the the heavy globalist conspiracy is bad, you you
make the 15% of richest people or the people who can vote, congratulations.
You're eating the bugs tomorrow. There's going to be farms. They're
going to pave over Asthma Gold's house and they're going to put
up big cement blocks of farms and cricket farms, okay? So, you
can eat the bugs. He's like actually arguing against every single
person in his audience, too. Like, at the same time, cricket
protein is good for you. That's what they say. would take away
their right to vote and they would be saying after 10 years,
20 years, thank you. Thank you so much for removing this burden
from us. We no longer have to worry about this. We don't have
to deal with this anymore. You're just going to have the people
that are in charge deal with the issues about getting rid of
the bottom 2%. Absolutely. Yes. And so that's it. That That's
what I would do. There are too many dumb people out
>> This guy doesn't This guy doesn't realize how he sounds.
Yeah, thank you. Thank you, Master Asmin. Thank you, Master Asmin.
Thank you. Thank you. I I don't think he understands that people
would not feel good about a society where they don't get a vote
and they get taxed or you is he just arguing you give up all
the tax revenue? I have no idea.
What about Andrew Wilson's idea where only people who do some
sort of civil service can vote? I don't think that was what I
don't think that's what Andrew's idea was. I think Andrew said
it was civil service if you don't own land or aren't like a positive
taxpayer, right? That like you can gain your vote if you aren't
a positive. I think that's what it was. But all positive because
the most important thing for the US government is the budget.
Okay. If you cut out any tax owners, you're [__]
or sorry taxpayers, you're [__] That's the That's
the big thing is no taxation without representation. And if you
try to overturn that, I don't know where you even go from there.
Yeah. So he's he's describing something that also Yeah. cuts
out his entire audience. Back in the day, we used to have presidents
like Thomas Jefferson. And now we have slave >> Presidents
like George W. Bush. Nope. Not a slave owner. Okay, I know which
one of those people I think is like a better person. Like Thomas
Jefferson. And now we have presidents like George W. Bush. Nope.
Nope. Nope. Not anymore. Think about how close Kamala Harris
came to winning the presidency. And then tell >> does he
not realize that this is like so Asminold is arguing for the
Richard Hanania world in every possible sense while not understanding
that he is writing out his entire ideology from existing that
he only exists as a function of a special moment in time where
the most ideas flourish and he is writing himself out of existence
and he doesn't even realize it is the irony. The irony is totally
lost on him. Amazing.
You'll love to see it. you
love love to see it. Okay. Me that democracy is a good idea.
We got to do something about this quick. Things are going to
get real bad. Oh yeah. And uh yeah, they're dumbass. But this
great I tell you I tell you that is And why is he doing Wait,
did the spirit of Vasha's ancestor just enter him? Wait, where
did this come from? What? >> Things are going to get real
bad. Oh, yeah. And uh yeah, they're dumbass. But this great I
tell you I tell you that this and and the thing is that guys
clip it. I'm ahead of the curve. I'm just ahead of the curve
there. This is going to be a bigger conversation every year.
He's way behind the curve. He's way behind the curve of disc
discussing that like I don't think democracy works. He's way
behind the curve. If you haven't gotten to the point where you
realize that tragically there is just no way to not enter a dystopian
like fascist future
and take away people's votes once you've once you've like really
come to grips with that that this is the best system and come
what may right you're you're behind the curve and he's just starting
to engage with it. He's like have you guys ever thought about
like people are dumb and maybe not everyone should vote. I'm
way ahead of the curve guys. Nobody's thought about this one.
Have you ever thought about like letting the plebs vote? I does
Hasbold is Hasbold aware that that was like a major concern
of Thomas Jefferson
like Thomas Jefferson would have been quite concerned that the
plebs could [__]
They made the whole Senate to check the power of the plebeian
masses.
That's a part of your country's founding
here. It's going to be a bigger conversation, a bigger issue.
And so too close. Yeah, way too close. And so just way uh hold
on. Is Asmin okay with being a part of the group that won't be
able to vote? So Sophia, he would always say yes. If if they
if they we decide that it's a system that works for America,
of course I'd give up my right to vote. He's going to do that
because he is a grifter. Wait up. How will people move up? I
don't know. It doesn't matter. It's not about that. It's about
making sure that the government isn't run by that's it. >> It's
about making sure the government isn't run by Which way is he
going on this? I actually don't know.
There's no way. He's like hitting himself in the face repeatedly
and he doesn't understand
at all. I'm I'm super Dude, this could easily be
it. It's like the exact Richard Hania post there. Uh without
the democracy demolishing. Hania is saying we gatekeep social
media democracy like flourishes again. Asold saying, "No, no,
no. Get rid of the democracy. We need social media. Get rid of
the democracy." Very interesting. I wonder why Asminold wouldn't
want to get rid of the social media. Yes, I know. We We can all
see the irony. Stall. I know. I know. It's up, dude. It's up.
All right, I'm gonna end on Twitch a little early tonight, I
think. Wait, why? How did I get
Someone just link me this picture of Pisco with the mustache.
Okay,
we got Pisco with a mustache here and then the follow-up image.
What? What? Why? What? What? What the What the We love We love
Pisco. We love Pisco.
Okay,
but that is haunting. Why you get the same glasses though? Okay,
that'll be Pisco. Pisco's my boy. Pisco is my boy. Never doubt
it. I'm gonna end on Twitch pretty early tonight. Let me go.
Uh, it's kick.com/jstalkk,
guys.
All right. Head on over. We'll be there all night. Okay. All
night. Okay. Let me switch over to off of multireaming
and Oh boy. Okay.
So, we watched the Asmin Gold thing. I think that's really funny
that Asmin Gold like it's just it's really funny to me that these
things get released at like the same time. Hanani article and
this Asmin Gold clip of him just making an app of himself. Okay.
I'm missing evil Johnny Bravo. You sent another message. Oh,
I really think we should watch Asmin's reaction to an idiocracy
video essay one of these days. It's unreal.
Wait, what? I don't know what you're talking about, but shoot
me uh shoot me a link. Maybe we'll check it out
cuz I think this is going to be I think this is like a central
theme that I like moving forward with on the stream cuz I love
conspiracies, right? I love conspiracies. I feel like I can understand
and participate and also say why things are bad or why or like
talk about how you can like not fall for them in the same way.
I love conspiracy theories and I think I'm uniquely positioned
to go watch Candace spew some conspiracies and then also go but
really but really
I don't think Israel did it. But really
I think Charlie Kirk probably just got shot by a crazy person.
Okay. All right. I got one more article. Oh no. I'll cover this
as a part of a different segment. I want to get to Candace. Give
me a second if you want it. It'll make us all mold. Okay. I got
this going in the docket. Give me a sec. Asthma slop. Okay. We
got some Asthma slop after maybe after the Candace stuff. We'll
see. We got legal docs. We got Candace slop and we got uh Asthma
slop. Okay. What a do what a docket. Let's see this Candace Owens.
So if you guys don't remember, Candace said she had texts and
stuff that would prove that that Charlie Kirk was not that cool
with Israel and stuff was really up actually. Okay. And she decided
to go live and release that stuff today. I'm kind of dubious.
I don't if you remember when Candace Owens actually produces
her receipts essentially every time she totally blows it, right?
She just totally [__] it up. So, she like doesn't
have the evidence that she suggested. She's making a total act
of herself, right? Every single time. Let's check it out. Let's
see what she Let's see what she was cooking here. >> Happy
Monday, everybody. Today, >> a long video TP USA, the little
lies, and David Hogan.
David Hogan. Is that like David Gogggins,
David Hog? How did she explain away the love letter Kirk wrote
to Netanyahu? I would love to see. I would love to know. She
says she can prove that Charlie was feeling bullied by Israel
in the last two days of his life. Okay,
so we'll we'll tune in. We'll check it out. Let me hit play.
I'm going to use the bathroom really quickly. I need to get my
water as well. So, give me two seconds. I'll be right >> So,
let me put it to you this way. I'll give you a different scenario.
If at this very moment McDonald's publicly announced that their
CEO was stepping down and they were going to replace him with
somebody else, nobody would care, right? Like there's not going
to be any public outcry
about them doing that. The average person doesn't even know who
the current CEO of McDonald's actually is. But however, giving
you a different scenario, if out of nowhere McDonald's announced
that they were getting rid of the Big Mac, that they were changing
their French fries, and they're doing away with their chicken
nuggets, there would probably be a reaction to that. People would
be pretty angry. It would probably start trending. Uh, and it's
because the reality is nobody actually cares about the corporate
structure.
But if you change the menu items, that actually changes the substance
of the company for people. A very recent example of that, by
the way, is the Cracker Barrel scandal, which was hilarious,
but it was a good point for everybody to learn, right? Corporate
over at Cracker Barrel effed around and they found out pretty
quickly that that old man on the logo, that inanimate old man
that was with the cracker and the barrel, actually had more meaning
to the public than their entire corporate division. They were
ready to just walk away. I'm back >> from it all because
they got rid of the old man and his barrel. Now, I raised this
only to say that I have seen
>> I just feel like they people did that because they feel
like they got to die on every hill, right? That's really what
it was about. They just feel like they got to die on every single
possible hill
every single possible time.
What Why am I getting sent photoshops of Pisco? This is This
is messed up. gay.
This is messed up. I got to I got a face reveal if I'm going
to be showing up showing all these pictures of Pisco laughing
about his mustache. Okay, that's that's messed up on my part.
All right, that's messed up.
Yeah, people just want to die on every hill about everything
all the time. It's kind of goofy. So political organizations
within recent years, especially when money starts pouring in,
right? There's this like arrogance that sets in and they start
to delude themselves into believing that they're smarter than
Yeah, I'm not even making fun of them. I'm not even making fun
of Pisco. I'm like I'm just laughing. It's just some funny stuff.
Okay. >> Their customers that they're smarter than their
audience, so to speak, right? Like the magic is actually the
corporate structure. Audiences,
uh, I want to be very clear, will catch a vibe pretty quickly.
Audiences are smart. They're perceptive. They will sense when
something is off. And the harder that you try to convince them
that their senses are not real and that they are imagined, the
more obvious it it actually becomes to them, that their suspicions
are correct, something's not right. Now, to just keep up with
the same analogy, Charlie Kirk was essentially the old man on
the Cracker Barrel logo. People were invested in Charlie Kirk.
We have at this moment no definitive un >> Oh, right. She
uh she hates Erica Kirk now too, doesn't she? No, she can't.
I don't know what she thinks about TPUSA.
I feel like she's got to have done some weird commentary on Erica
Kirk, though, at this point. >> Understanding of what happened
on the day that he was assassinated. But what we do know definitively
is that the feds are lying to us. That is obvious. It is abundant.
If you have a if you're able to think thought >> about
what >> you recognize that something is very wrong with
the story that has been presented to the public and I think that
what the public doesn't understand and I count myself
>> Oh, I see. She says she's being used and Erica's silence
means Candace is telling the truth. That like if if Candace was
lying, why wouldn't Erica Kirk come out and say she was lying?
I see. I got it. Oh man, I I just wish
So she says the FBI is lying. She t she came out a couple days
ago and she said that Tyler Robinson's parents said he didn't
turn himself in and that he wasn't guilty and he wasn't even
there or some
so I do think listen she makes a lot of claims
and I just want to see you know any evidence of those claims
>> among the public is why it seems as though Turning Point
USA executives and I'll say seems are not even remotely
interested in challenging that official narative They're not
interested in challenging it publicly at least. In fact, I think
it was an ex user that pointed out, he put it rather bluntly
when he said, "So, they want us to forgive Tyler Robinson, but
to attack the people that are trying to solve the murder of Charlie
Kirk." Like, that's not right. That doesn't feel right. That
doesn't feel good of threats of lawsuits. We're collecting evidence
of what what are we even talking about? And I want to say that
what's been bothering me in particular are the micro lies. seems
that they're suddenly in the business of telling micro lies,
tiny little misrepresentations,
tiny little half-truths
that right out of the gate seems altogether unnecessary. It really
>> I Okay,
I I just wish Candace would attach any of her like accusations
in stuff like this with like an example right away. She just
waits so long every single time to attach any example. makes
me wonder who are they protecting exactly.
You'll see oftent times they and other influencers will invoke
Erica as the reason that it's not appropriate to ask questions.
It's just not appropriate while Erica is still mourning for you
guys to ask any questions and I'm just going to come back at
you with some common sense. What sort of widow wouldn't want
people to investigate the assassination of their husband? She
has not explicitly said that, but the influencers are invoking
that, right? They're invoking like you just it's not appropriate
right now for people to be >> I think probably what's happening
is Candace isn't doing like some sort of well-founded, well sourced
document on why she thinks the the investigators are lying. She's
just going live and doing like a bunch of hinting at a possible
thing and then getting 100,000 viewers and making a bunch of
money and then she goes and rides off into the sunset without
ever making like very substantive claims or trying to prove anything.
So while we would say we want the truth on whatever happened
to Charlie, we want the truth from investigators and anyone else,
you are not trying to provide it. You are just like grandstanding
repeatedly
which probably the disgusting thing here >> questions.
That's what I mean when I say they are David hogging us. Okay,
you could also use another example. Um, somebody that was on
the right, Kyle Kushv, what essentially means is that when a
tragedy takes place and we are all we we are emotional, our emotions
are raw. Me especially, I think this was the first time where
I couldn't really check my emotions. I I I'm just now like moving
out of the grief stage.
There will be people that then will try to manipulate you, right?
They will try to manipulate you by using that strategy of saying,
"Well, it would be really wrong. It would be really wrong for
you to look beneath this layer or to ask a question about this."
And it, you know, it would be an injustice to Charlie Kirk's
legacy. Really, if you really loved him, then you shouldn't do
this, okay? Because the tragedy just happened and they did this
David Hog. You're not allowed to question David Hog. that he
suddenly became an authority and no matter what he said, we were
kind of told by >> I just I think Candace is just taking
like a couple comments from people and she's totally misrepresenting
them, right? I don't know. She basically just she does the the
Vosch thing, right? The Vosch thing from like 2022 where he'll
just like describe a situation. He'll never grab clips or anything.
He'll just describe all of this stuff and there's never like
evidence of it. He's just describing like he's giving a vibe
out. It's just it's just like putting a vibe out into the world.
>> The journal journalist that it just made perfect sense
and he should go to Harvard and obviously to the extent that
anybody suffers and survives a a school shooting, I'm with you.
And I think that that's totally fair. But then when you go beyond
that, it starts to feel a little bit like you're emotionally
manipulating us and that you're actually trying to silence people
who have valid questions or criticisms or concerns. >> That
strategy, like I said, it worked on me in the beginning. I was
definitely completely worked by it and I was feeling like even
though I knew that they were telling white lies that I should
just allow it and to instead focus my entire attention on just
unpacking the federal lies. But you know what? Over the weekend
I realized actually no. Lying full stop is weird. It's weird
after a tragedy. It is weird after someone that you purport to
be your best friend. You're so close. Why are you telling micro
lies about that person? And actually by exposing those lies perhaps
it will reveal a bigger picture because what would motivate it?
What would actually motivate it? Now, I'll give you just one
example here, and we're going to get into some some stuff that's
rather >> Thank you. that Oh my god, finally. >> Fantastic.
I'm being frank. But one example that I bit my tongue on a couple
weeks ago was when influencers randomly went on a full attack,
like full attack mode against me when I very casually, you guys
watching this series, very casually mentioned that Catholics
were hoping that Charlie's going to take the next step and and
convert. Like, of course, I'm Catholic. Of course, what would
be wrong with >> That's not even close to the worst thing
you said. That's not even close to the thing people were most
annoyed about from you. It's not close. She's just she's just
like going to go uh every single time with all of these people
they go, "Dude, everybody's coming after me for like, you know,
wanting universal healthcare." No, no, no, no. Actually, actually
deal
actually deal with like the allegations you were making. That
wasn't the most serious thing you suggested. >> With me
sharing that, everybody was sharing their stories about Charlie
and the conversations they were having. But for some reason,
Candace saying, and I'll sum it up effectively, it was like two
sentences. Charlie was going through some spiritual changes towards
the end. Catholics were hoping that he'd take the next step because
he was praying the rosary. I never said he converted cuz he didn't.
That would have been dishonest. But people were somehow really
angry. Somebody clearly hit the panic button. Suddenly a bunch
of videos were being made disputing the narrative. People were
going, "I knew Charlie and he was truly evangelical to his core."
Blah blah blah blah blah blah. And I want to tell you this, it
felt coordinated. It felt fake. It felt unnecessary. But most
importantly, it was untrue. Okay? It wasn't true. And I'm going
to share with you some more truth so that you can contextualize
it. Charlie was attending mass weekly. He was sometimes even
attending mass daily. He was not attending Pastor Rob McCoy's
church as I mentioned before. Uh yes, he was praying the rosary.
Charlie, in fact, was wearing the St. Michael pendant when he
died. Okay, as has already been publicized, Erica took a Catholic
bishop with her to pray over his body on the day that he died.
These are all individual facts. And it is also a fact which was
presented by Megan Kelly uh that a few weeks before his death,
Erica had a priest come over to pray over them when some witches
thought it would be funny whatever uh to put a hex on him.
>> that's a lot. He was not. No, he was not Catholic. She's
not even saying he converted. Erica grew up Catholic.
>> Yeah. Okay. I
Man.
Uh, I'm just going to hit play. I >> She's She always does
this where she's like, "No, no, no. Don't say that I said X thing."
When she like hints so hard at it, she puts her whole body into
hinting at a direction and then she'll go, "Whoa, people like
said I said this." No, I did not. No, I did not. It's like Candace,
you were leaning super hard into trying to tell us that Charlie
was sincerely thinking about converting. Like 100% you were.
Why are you trying to make it seem like that's not what you were
saying? >> Things that were happening behind the scenes
and the people at Turning Point USA knew those things to be true.
Okay, they knew everything that I just shared with you. They
knew for a fact. So, I was a bit astonished when Andrew Kovette
and Alex Clark similarly jumped in in this inauthentic attempt
to dissuade the idea that Charlie was softening on Catholicism.
It read to me like just sheer hatred of Catholics for no reason
at all. Here's what they said. I'll jog your memory. I want you
to listen to this. No, I I'm guessing the people around Charlie
and especially in TPUSA were pretty sincere in their belief.
And you trying to hint that he was not sincere in his belief
or that he was having reservations about their denomination?
That is offensive in general. Yes. Hey, the guy who I think is
a hero of my denomination specifically, you're saying he was
not sincerely believing or his faith was uh shaken in my denomination.
That is insulting to my denomination. And I want to clear that
up. >> Now, in the context of all of the additional details
that I just shared with you, okay, take a listen. Was he becoming
Catholic? >> No. But he really loved Catholic mass. He
loved the ritual of it. Uh he loved the beauty of old Catholic
churches and the stained glass >> and him and Erica would
go sometimes. >> Yeah. Well, Erica's a cradle Catholic.
Uh but she ended up kind of like me. I grew up Catholic and first
communion and went to Catholic high school, but then I ended
up becoming a Christian in college through a Protestant church
through a non-denominational kind of more experience. It was
actually Presbyterian and then it was kind of non non non-denominational.
And and I think Erica kind of follows that same path. She and
I share that. Also, by the way, I just want to draw attention
to she's posted a photo of her and Charlie and the kids in mass
before and somebody in the comment section said, "Oh, are you
guys converting?" And she said, "No, we just like attending sometimes."
So, she herself had said no. >> Yeah. And I think Charlie
one of one of the things Charlie really hated worshiping in like
a a gym, you know, or a some sort of kind of blank space that
that you just turn into church. I don't there's no problem. He
didn't have a problem with the the act of that. He just didn't
prefer it. And he loved again the ritual, the ancient >> Charlie
was a vibes guy. Okay. Charlie wanted the aesthetics.
Don't put me in some blank mega church with a a huge like neon
sign for a cross. Okay. Put me in an old school cathedral
with stained glass windows and art on the walls. Okay, I get
it. I get it.
You know, feel of a Catholic mass and the fact that everybody
around the world that was worshiping as is Catholic. He loved
he loved that. So, he had some really big theological hang-ups
with that. can go check the videos out him debating with uh Michael
Nolles, you know, in good fun. I mean, they were dear friends,
but they loved kind of debating the whole Protestant versus Catholic
thing. >> Now, given everything that I've I've shared with
you, does that conversation register as like totally and completely
authentic or kind of trying to be like, yeah, no, like he loved
the architecture of things, but beyond that, nothing was happening.
Like, that's not that's not >> I don't even think they
I don't even think he said nothing was happening. I think he
said that like he loved the ritual of it and he was like
he appreciated it. I don't think it's like, oh, he felt nothing.
Is it clear that he felt something for sure? That guy kind of
confirms it. It doesn't mean he was converting. It doesn't mean
something changed. Fully honest. And it registered to me like
a cover up of sorts. And I was wondering like what are we exactly
covering up? Like I wasn't going Catholic gang gang. Wasn't trying
to bring back a 30 years war. I was just sharing
>> the communications that I had with him. And now I felt
like suddenly so many people were racing to establish that his
legacy was anything but Catholic. Catholic, right? like he was
super duper Judeo-Christian
and ironically it was Judeo-Christianity that I was challenging
him on personally like privately. Um and I was speaking to him
about the political pressures of it the way that I felt.
>> I don't
I
don't know the differentiation here. I don't know why is it just
is she just going to say this is all I know is the Fentes talking
point on this which is well you know Jesus. So the idea that
you could be Judeo-Christian when the the Jews that were you
know the that participated in keeping Christ the
are basically the only sect remaining they passed down like the
rabbitical teachings rabbitical Judaism. So actually any like
there is a harsh cut off between Christianity and the people
who rejected Jesus totally wholesale right and I I agree with
that to some sense or in some sense but it's like you do share
the Judeo-Christ Christian thing. It's like if you want to throw
out the Old Testament, go ahead. But you share a common like
story, a common uh origination point with with Judaism. It's
hard to can't throw that away. I don't know. >> Um because
of last year that it registered to me like more of a cult than
a true theology or a religion or a religious aspect rather. And
it was back in February of this year when out of nowhere he's
the one that actually messaged me and said um I'm sorry of of
and said Catholicism is sounding better and better in February
of 2024. This is kind of when we started having that discussion.
Uh, we should chat soon. Catholicism is looking better and better.
Okay. I then offered back to him a chart just showing how the
phrase of Christianity kind of is really >> What the
This is so insane,
dude. Hey, I'm uh I'm like having, you know, some shaking. My
faith is a bit shaky. I I feel like there's a lot to Catholicism.
I'm feeling a lot from the mass. And she was like, "Suck. Invented
I thanks Candace. Thanks. Thanks for that, Candace. really cool
of you to respond to my talking about how Catholicism looks good
with you a chart of the popularity of the term
This this is like an insane exchange. I'm sorry. This is like
a absurd exchangeated with the dawn of the nation of Israel,
right? >> Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry. Uh, Kuryoko, you
can separate Christianity from modern Judea uh, Judaism teachings
from from rabbitical Judaism that there was a there there's like
a schism in Old Testament to New Testament teachings and like
it goes in a different direction like they are oppositional as
in the people who are handing down the rabbitical teachings are
people who explicitly rejected Jesus Christ. So you could say
that there's no way to separate them, but it's like the separation
was done on the basis of whether or not you thought Jesus was
the >> And we did chat about it. We chat about talked about
it a lot and I was thrilled, like I said, and I was being honest
that he was attending mass. Okay. But I want to again state that
Charlie was not attending Robin Koy's church. He was attending
mass. So it registered to me again as somewhat disingenuous when
pastor Rob McCoy came out and effectively asked me to, you know,
stop looking into all of the things that had happened in the
lead to Charlie Kirk's assassination or at least asking me to
pause it rather would be more fair of an interpretation until
the memorial. Right? I'm going to jog your memory here. Here
is what pastor Rob McCoy wrote on his Instagram after I exposed
the now infamous Hampton's meeting which took place. He wrote
this. Charlie Kirk was my friend and I was his pastor. I want
to simply say this regarding Candace Owens. Charlie Kirk was
a friend to Candace. Never publicly spoke poorly of her. Although
he disagreed with her, he never operated nor entertained gossip
or innuendo concerning Candace. My only comment I offer regarding
Candace is this. I only wish that at this tragic time of mourning,
she would be the friend to Charlie that he was to her. He would
never have treated Candace or her family in such a way had God
forbid this tragedy been hers. All friend loves at all times.
Proverbs. Now, I want to be very clear. If Charlie was a friend
of mine, I sure hope I was assassinated in front of the world
that he would that he would raise hell to figure out what actually
took place in that day. That's not being a friend. A friend is
not someone who stays silent uh when lies are being told by the
federal government. That's not a friend of Again, emotionally
manipulative. The family can't have you finding out who actually
killed him. The family can't have you looking into those things
of who was pressuring him behind the scenes. That's just that's
not good for the family.
It bothers me. I have to be honest with you. That bothers me.
I don't even like that to the untrained eye he's kind of representing
himself or representing Charlie as like a current congre congregant
of his church. I feel like a lot this year I have been feeling
as those as though these pastors
are just not as honest as they should be. Right. Is that the
vibe? Like a lot of pastors are not really so concerned with
the truth is what I would say. So we should zero in here on Rob
and what his motivations might. >> I Okay. It sounds like
this guy probably heard that you were I don't know talking about
Charlie, talking about conspiracy theories around Charlie and
didn't like that. I don't I don't know why she she's zoning in
on one pastor. >> Might be seems like an odd choice. >> Why
did he decide to post this after I revealed that Hampton's meeting?
Well, you should know, I think most people do, that both his
son and his daughter-in-law work for Turning Point USA. So whether
you want to represent that or not, they have a financial stake
in the future of the company. He heads up the faith division.
So Charlie's faith and what direction it was going into would
actually matter, right? It would actually matter if Charlie,
and I never said he was going to, decided one day to become Catholic.
It would have financial implications.
want to be clear. I never had a conversation that that Charlie
was in the process of converting. Okay. >> Okay. Hold on.
Hold on. Hold on. I don't think that's true.
I don't think that's true. Hold on. >> But Rob in particular
knew for an absolute fact that Charlie was done with Israel bullying
him. That's what bothers me so much about this man. Him allowing
these headlines. Charlie's pastor speaks out, you know, crushes
Candace because of what she not whatever. I don't like it. He
knew and others knew that Charlie was done with Israel bullying
him. And I'm now going to present you proof of what I am saying.
This is an actual group chat which happened two days before Charlie
Kirk was assassinated. There were nine people in total on this
chat including Charlie uh and Rob McCoy. I'm going to protect
the names of the other seven for now. To be clear, I might actually
release a name every day this week. But I want
>> want to show you this because suffice it to say Rob
McCoy was on this text thread and I think it helps contextualize
him as a person in my view that he would attack me for telling
the truth about the pressure that he was facing. Take a look.
So Charlie writes in this group chat just lost another huge donor
uh 2 million a year because we won't cancel Tucker. I'm thinking
of inviting Candace. Somebody writes
>> Okay. Oh, this is kind of funny. Somebody sent this
to her. Just lost another huge donor. 2 million a year because
he won't we won't cancel Tucker. I'm thinking of inviting Candace.
Duke donors play into all the stereotypes. I cannot and will
not be bullied like this. Leaving me no choice but to leave the
pro Israel cause.
Oh boy.
Oh boy. So the uh dickers, thank the raid. Let's go. Is that
Charlie Kirk messaging her? This is a group chat without Candace
in it. This Candace is not in this group chat. Candace is being
leaked this group chat probably by some participant in the group
chat,
right? So, there's some group chat that she's part that Charlie
is in and he's like, "Oh, we lost this uh we lost the sponsor
and now I'm thinking about inviting Candace." I just I love how
spitebased Charlie Kirk is. You know what? Donors
donors dropping out. You know what? I might invite Candace. Maybe
I'll just bring Candace.
See See how much Benny Netanyahu likes that one. That's pretty
funny when he decides his viewpoints. I don't know. Listen, if
they're going to take that 2 million away, maybe I go pro Palestine.
I think he's probably just feeling like uh angry about this,
hearing about this, right, over the Tucker thing. Writes, donors
play into all of the stereotypes. I cannot and will not be bullied
like this, leaving me no choice but to leave the pro-Israel cause.
And somebody writes, donor writes, please do not invite Candace.
That might feel good short term, but it's not good long term.
In my opinion, like all groups, you're going to get a wide variety
of opinions. That nasty free will thing that God bestowed on
us makes life frustrating at times. After the dust settles a
bit, maybe
so again, this is 48 hours before Charlie was assassinated. He
was very >> So, I will say if if she doesn't reveal more
of these group chats, right, I'm going to be like a little concerned
that
he sort of comes around on this very quickly and goes like, I
know, I know I shouldn't be like this uh this angry about stuff.
I need to see more of that group chat. I if you get one tight
screenshot of a group chat saying like look this is what really
happened there's no reason to believe that that this person's
lying to you >> clear and he was very explicit and he did
not back down not in that Hampton's meeting which they're all
lying about nor in this text thread I'm not going to reveal the
names of the other seven actually you know what I disagree with
myself 4 seconds ago let's just throw in Josh Hammer for funies
he's on this chat okay so what are we to make of that okay now
that I'm showing you this and showing to you that the >> guess
what I'm going to name it every day of the week and I said I
was going to name one today But here's one today. Josh Hammer.
Josh Hammer. Josh Hammer. Now, is Josh Hammer the He's not the
Babylon B guy, right? Josh Hammer was at that was at that Hampton's
meeting. Who's this guy? This guy is an American conservative
political commentator, attorney, and columnist. Josh Hammer.
Okay. Got it. Got it. Got it. Got it. Got it. >> The conversations
were real. I want you to reflect, and it took me a lot of patience
to allow the lies that were being woven and the misrepresentations.
This is the guy who debated Dave Smith at one of his things that
everybody was mad about. Right. >> Pretending that I was
just what? High on lying about Charlie and the pressure he was
under. The attacks that not just me, Tupper Carlson, Megan Kelly
faced for trying to stand up and tell the truth about what Charlie
was actually going through. Why are you hearing it though from
me and Tucker Carlson and Megan Kelly? Is that weird? You got
people that are hosting a show. Have they in like one honorable
thing come out and said like, "You know what? f a couple of these
donors who made his life a living hell in the last couple of
weeks. Why haven't they done that? There's also a rabbi in that
chat. Like, why hasn't anybody made that move to at least say
to vindicate what I have been saying about what he was going
through? That registers to me as very suspicious. I'm going to
frankly say that it's suspicious to me. It makes me think that
in the way in the same way that Charlie was being pressured by
money that you might be now >> Why didn't anybody in that
group chat like rush to help me? Is there something like from
the past like year, maybe 18 months, that makes me unreliable
that would like make it so none of those people would rush to
help me? Why wouldn't any of them come to help me? I'm Candace
Owens. >> I'll run by that same money that those same donors
might be running you to correct the ship and to focus yourselves
on eulogizing Charlie as something and someone that never once
flinched, never once for a single second doubted the Israeli
cause.
Will she will she materially like engage with the fact I believe
that she said the letter that Charlie Kirk sent to Netanyahu
was not great. Right. I believe she talked about that letter.
I can't find it right now, but I think she talked about that
letter and said it was like, oh, he was like cold to Netanyahu.
He didn't want to go to Israel. He didn't want to do any of that.
And then we got an like a copy of the letter and he was like
slobbing Netanyahu's knob and trying to be like, "You need to
do this, this, this, and that to make sure Israel's protected."
So I I wonder if she talks about that at all. Now they want us
to suddenly believe the best way to honor Charlie is to shut
up. The exact opposite of what he quite literally laid down his
life doing. Answering questions. Turning points. Answering the
questions is what he was doing in the second that he died. Okay?
And we all feel we all are feeling >> that's actually not
true. He actually very quite he quite explicitly dodges a lot
of the questions he's asked and totally like sidesteps them and
goes down a different line. Right. So I believe it was like do
you think it was something about trans school shooters and he
was like what did he say? What did he say in response?
He said some I can't remember what he said in response but it
was like it was like an evasion. That was like the literal response
>> spiritually the same way. So I'm just going to say it.
They're not >> Oh. Oh, do we include gang violence in those
numbers? Right. >> Grieving rights. >> It's like
it's literally an evasion that he responds with. >> It's
not up to us to decide how people grieve, but I will say unequivocally
that you shouldn't grieve by lying or by gaslighting. Is that
fair? Can we all agree you should not grieve by lying and gaslighting
the public. They want us to believe that the only way that we
can support and honor Charlie's legacy is by donating our money.
But it would not be supportive for us to try to figure out who
killed him and why the feds are lying. we should instead just
trust the feds and excuse their little halftruths that they're
telling along the way. Now, on that point, they keep trying to
make it seem like it's completely normal that 4 minutes after
Charlie was shot, someone on their team nervously raced to grab
the SD cards uh specifically from >> Hey, wait, the feds
or is it from Turning Point USA? Cuz now she was like, I only
have questions for the feds and now she's expressing some questions
for Turning Point. the camera that is behind Charlie's head.
And um that was because during that time they think it's like
trying to make it normal that his instinct was to stand on Charlie's
chair to actually violate a crime scene. >> Okay. What
what prevents the thought process there from being oh I don't
want people getting like 4K views of him like falling to the
ground?
Why would that not be the the possible thought process of the
guy from Turning Point? Oh, I should grab those just in case
somebody runs out of the crowd, grabs those things while nobody's
paying attention and post it on the internet, and I don't want
that. >> But also to mysteriously just grab the SD card
out of the camera, right? Not only are they pretending that that
was completely normal, but they're also presenting it as though
it was a heroic act. It was like a forthright, clarified act
to do in that moment, and that anyone who uses their own eyes
and sees it as maybe a little bit suspicious are just in the
business of spinning conspiracies now. >> Nope. Nope. I
could totally see how that would make you suspicious if there
were a lot of other things that added up and added to this conspiracy.
I've seen almost nothing that points to like a significant conspiracy
here. Um I've watched we've watched a lot of the videos.
I don't see anything that's pointing to a crazy conspiracy unless
you want to argue the entire FBI is framing Tyler Robinson, right?
But without a lot of evidence other than just like, oh, these
text messages look weird. It looks like they doctorred them.
That's exactly what was communicated by Andrew Kovette um when
he sat across from Tucker Carlson who was hosting Charlie's show
and gratefully Tucker Carlson instantly responded with a much
more sensible approach. Take a listen. >> By the way, just
one other conspiracy theory I just want to snuff out here. One
of our dear friends that literally from the very beginning started
with us. >> Bro, this guy
I I I
don't think this guy's related somehow. I feel like he he's got
like a little bit of Charlie Kirk little bit of the Charlie Kirk
facial features. I don't know why. >> And love Charlie
like a brother. He grabbed the SD cards out of the camera afterwards.
And there's all these conspiracy videos about why did he grab
the SD cards? Well, first of all, they're in the possession of
the FBI. Okay, it's not like he took them and like ran off with
them. Second of all, I asked him personally. I said, "Why did
you do that?" And he looked at me and this was his answer. He
said, "Because I know people can be evil."
And he did not want that footage being grabbed by somebody. There
was videos of people after the incident going and ste >> like
I yeah I literally that's my first thought is oh you know something
horrible just happened. I don't want people putting my friend's
like corpse on the internet. That's not I don't like that. I
don't want that.
I don't know >> peeling hats off the table. I mean so I'm
so grateful he did that and that that was his instinct. He's
like I'm depressed to know that that was why I did that. But
I knew that I had to protect that footage because I know I wanted
I mean you know you're recording in like 4K you know and so I'm
so glad he did that but Charlie knew the existence of evil and
so >> can I say I think that people can feel the existence
of evil in that just to put in a sympathetic word for people
who are trying to make sense of this and coming to the wrong
conclusions. I think they're motivated for the most part by pure
intent. I think they don't trust the authorities. They have every
reason to feel that way. I know that for a fact. Not the Trump
administration in general like we're not you know there's been
a lot of lying and it's corroded the trust. That's not their
fault. actually they're the victims at that >> Yeah, thank
you Tucker for saying that and this is the reason why Tucker
is so big because he he has this perspective. he understands
like what the average person is thinking here and the average
person looks at that and I think it's shady and you know saying
that there was this heart-wrenching moment where you were worried
because people were stealing stuff on the table but also you
took the SD card out and not the very expensive camera which
is if you were worried about stealing and theft maybe you would
take the camera but more >> that but he wasn't worried
they weren't worried about theft they were worried about people
grabbing that footage and putting it on the internet that the
theft wasn't their concern they're not like mad that people stole
the hats they're Yeah she didn't listen at all not even a little
Or or maybe she did. Listen, she's very good at this. She does
this very intentionally a lot of the time. She will not engage
correctly because she doesn't want to like actually deal with
what people are saying. She wants to paint a narrative and get
people to keep listening to her. >> Importantly there is
he says that the feds that he he gave it to the feds, right?
And he doesn't insinuate obviously that they don't have the footage.
Turning Point does have the footage. That's very clear. I saw
part partially the footage which means they made it back home.
Uh or maybe they had it back home because they were um recording
it live. whatever it is, uh, it was being live streamed. But
what he said actually conflicts with what Tyler Boyer is about
to say, what he said over this weekend. Okay, Tyler Boyer, like
I said, he's a COO of Turning Point Action, and he went on this
kind of bender, uh, worst kind of bender, Twitter bender, defending
the organization. He thought he was defending them against public
sentiments during which time he refused what Andrew Kovette is
saying about the SD cards. Andrew says Turning Point employee
was worried about thefts, but Tyler says that actually he was
instructed to secure the SD cards before the campus went on to
lockdown. Now, here's the tweet. I can show you that. Uh, somebody
said, "Rightfully, emotional manipulation and falsely equating
scrutiny as some form of hate speech is not going to work here."
You and Kovette admitted that the staff tampered with >> Is
this the guy who grabbed it? Uh, this this was one I didn't even
think of, but law enforcement officers saying, "Hey, we need
those SD cards. That also makes total sense." >> With cameras
and the most crucial video evidence in the largest political
assassination in decades, hiding makes him look guilty. And Tyler
countered, "Dude did not tamper with anything." Yes, he did.
It's a crime scene. The law enforcement officers asked them to
turn them over immediately so they didn't get lost in commotion
before they took everyone into lockdown. Now, that is just not
true. That is not true. What Tyler was saying is not true. I
spoke to that turning point individual. I as I told you and he
never
once mentioned that police officers I explicitly asked him why
did you take the SD cards out specifically of the camera behind
and the answer that I was given which sounded more like Andrew
what Andrew Kovette said. You know, I was emotional. I I knew
that Charlie was dead and my instinct he told me was to take
make sure that I secured the footage so that Erica would not
have to see it again. >> Oh, that makes Okay, so
that makes total sense. What Andrew Kovit makes said makes total
sense. Andrew Kovit literally was leaning in that direction the
whole time he talked about it. Okay, so it's just what the natural
assumption you would make as a human being is exactly what they
said. And Candace is like trying to play around with like something
about theft and the and the hats to make it seem like they said
something else. >> Like he didn't want Erica to have to
see it and have to relive it. That is what he said to me on the
phone. Nothing about police officers. No one's ever heard police
officers asked them to secure the footage before lockdown until
Tyler Boyer tweeted this weekend. I don't like it. Okay. I just
don't like it. Now, to be fair, >> those two things are
both possible. By the way, that this guy grabbed the SD cards
and then the cops came along and were like, "Hey, can we get
that footage?" Right? Like obviously both of those things could
have happened in that precise order. >> Error. Uh Tyler
is making it clear that he is responding to all of these tweets
um or exes, whatever we're supposed to call them, because there
have been people, he says, that have flat out accused the organization
of having a hand in Charlie's murder. He doesn't share when or
where exactly that happened. Uh I think people feel you're being
dishonorable by not questioning the narrative, but I don't I
don't I haven't read anybody that's explicitly accused them of
murder. In fact, um the the tweets that he's responding to all
seem to be pretty fair in my opinion, you know. Um now, regarding
the missing campus footage, there is a user that begged Tyler
to file an FOIA request, and that user wrote this. Please, I
beg you, focus on getting the security footage of the sequence
pre- jump off the Loy building where we can see Robinson in shot
position and corroborate the story like fil sorry, violent FOIA.
Get that footage. Keep it simple. and he responds and he says,
"Guys, there's camera footage all over that campus that the police
have, plus all the cameras that we had. They likely won't release
it until the trial." Now, there's just one problem with that
narrative, right?
What I I think
I I'm very curious what her what like her response would be here.
It's like, "Oh, we're alleging that the cops are doing this,
so obviously the cops wouldn't be trustworthy."
I don't I don't even know what you could possibly have here,
cuz there's no reason to expect that footage before the trial
happens.
and they have all this footage and they're just not releas what
uh they're just worried about the trial. They want to make sure
they win the trial. What's wrong with that narrative is the manhunt
that took place. If indeed they have tons of footage from all
these different angles and some of it in 4K, which they do, this
is why we've been saying the feds are lying from day one, then
the first time that that footage should have been deployed was
during the 33-hour manhunt, right? Why >> Why would you
need something other than the best picture they had of his
How are you like looking for this guy's like gate or something?
You're trying to look like and see how he walks. I guess there's
footage of that anyway. She's like, "It's critical. We need to
see that guy take the shot to fire the weapon in order to hunt
him down." No, it's not. You see his shirt, you see his face.
They gave you what you needed for >> Why didn't they release
more footage at that time, right? They were if they were actually
in >> Yeah. How would that The question is just how would
that have helped? And she's never going to actually explain how
that would have helped, right? She's going to keep yapping about
nothing. just going to keep going. Well, isn't that weird that
they wouldn't do that? Isn't it strange that they like kept like
some of the footage to themselves? Why isn't there footage of
that guy running across the roof from like some camera over here?
Why did they release that publicly?
Yeah, that's just not how any police investigation works ever.
>> Interested in catching the killer. >> She thinks
everyone is stupid. Unfortunately for us, Oliver Brown, everyone
is stupid. Or at least a significant portion of people are stupid
and they do watch Candace and they do take her seriously.
So she is capable of lying to a bunch of different people.
>> Why only release a blurry image when there is as he
mentions footage everywhere all over that campus every inch.
Are we supposed to honestly believe at that time their thought
process in the middle of a manhunt was well let's not release
too much except for a blurry image because I know we don't have
him but in case we do have him when we do get him we want to
make sure that we are um able to try him by not releasing footage
which makes no sense by the way. I think this is what happens
when a company loses.
>> So, uh, hold on. I don't know if Asmin thinks she's
a smart truth teller. I don't think so. I think Asmin
Asmin, although it would make total sense for him to trust her,
he won't cuz Asmin is uh I think he's a little more sophisticated
than he lets on sometimes.
I think he he sometimes knows what he's doing. But um she's arguing
that you like need extra video of this guy doing things like
in the act of doing things
instead of
just the picture of his face and maybe some like directions he
went in like they they had the video of him falling down off
the roof or whatever that got released publicly. Why? How is
the video of him taking the shot helping the public manhunt >> is
there as South Park ribbed him? Master debater, right? What they're
saying does not make sense. These people could not win in college
campus debates without Charlie. Okay? Because the reality is
if that if releasing footage, okay, if releasing clear footage
of what happened on that day means that you are going to lose
in court,
then it probably signifies
that the person that you are trying to bring to court didn't
do it. And if they're somehow vindicated by the footage, if you're
like, I release the footage of him jumping down on the center
and I show him firing a shot, but like that totally vindicates
him, then you got the wrong guy, right? having more footage.
>> Uh what they probably want is for him to So what they
do when they're having these investigations, they hide all information.
They don't show it to anybody because they want to ask people
questions and see what they say and see if they contradict information
they have. It is one of the easiest ways to tell if somebody
should be a more like a a person of additional interest, right?
Is if you go and ask somebody and they tell you something that
directly conflicts with actual evidence you have because you
haven't released it. That is your best way of knowing whether
or not somebody should be like talk to more whether they might
be hiding something. So obviously they're not going to release
things that don't help with the manhunt, which is what she's
describing the video of him taking the shot. >> Examining
more footage and examining more evidence should further incriminate
Tyler Robinson. It should also go a very >> Also, I just
want to point out that Candace is acting like we don't have Hold
on. Listen. Oh, it should only It should only prove that it should
only prove that Charlie's innocent. Sorry that uh Tyler's guilty,
right? There's no way somebody could look at the the information
and just get the totally wrong idea, right? More information
is just always good, >> ladies and gentlemen. Every single
time. >> Oh, wait. Except the range day bro video with
our bush shooter. The [__] the bush shooter here.
Okay.
Like, how many do we need with multi-million view videos on YouTube
with garbage like this before you realize that more information
is not always good? It's not going to help. is not going to make
things better. Candace has take the taken the minimal amount
of information she has and spun a bunch of different random conspiracies
with it. Right. 6.4 million views. Yes. When he when By the way,
there's a picture of this from his next video. If you guys didn't
watch it when we covered this originally, there's a picture of
it in his next video where he shows that the Hold on. I could
I can actually just take a picture from here. Hold on. So, this
is He says this bush is like a shooter and then somebody sent
him like a 4K picture of the bush. Hold on.
raising.
This is It's literally just a plant. It's literally just a house
plant sitting there. Okay. And he he seriously went on his YouTube
account. He went to I guess like uh After Effect, not After Effects,
but um Oh, what is it? He went to whatever video editor uses.
Okay. And he he put this together and he was like, "Listen,
this this seems plausible to me."
Yeah. Yeah. But Cand Candace is arguing, "Hey, more footage that
would be great. That would solve all of our problems." No, it
wouldn't. No, >> way in getting people off of these quote
unquote conspiracies. Common sense is what I said at the beginning.
Release the footage, which you do have in your possession. It's
not like just the feds have this footage. Does he recover from
this career-ending blunder? Nobody will care. Uh he did he did
post a video debunking himself. I do think that helps, right?
It doesn't help enough. That's the unfortunate thing. >> Release
the footage because then people will move on from quote unquote
conspiracies. So, >> oh yeah, remember he had to explain.
Hold on. He did have to explain this. One second. He had to explain
in his next video. >> Ladies and gentlemen, I
>> because his audience was
His audience thought he did some kind of AI enhancement and that
this was the person. And his audience was like, "Wait, we could
probably find this person." He had to explain to his audience
that this was actually just a a picture he copy pasted in here,
for example, for reference. that this isn't actually some enhancement
he did on this pixelated piece of [__] It was No,
no, no. That's like a That's like a reference image I used, guys.
Is this SF fan's brother? It might be. Same beard.
Okay. Yes. He had to explain to people. No, no, no. That's not
really the guy. That's not the shooter. I'm not saying there's
a shooter. That's how that's how you are. Okay. That's how much
we needed
the actual elite gatekeeping everything. All right. Jesus. So
everything they're saying right now doesn't make sense. Um and
the they're not smarter than the public, right? And Turning Point
is not going going to survive this sort of an attitude, name
calling, threats to sue, um calling people demonic, possessed
by demonic spirits because they're rightfully asking questions
of the most high-profile political assassination since JFK. It's
just not going to work. Free PR advice. It is not going to work.
I want to show you one more thing too because I I am quite stunned
by the audacity um to call me out uh Alex Clark to like call
me out by sharing on her profile something that's just fundamentally
untrue. But before we do that, I'm going to go to a couple of
our sponsors. First, pre-born because I have watched many people
that I'm close with be vilified because they stood up for truth.
I've just myself and you're not chilling right now. >> Of
course, by donating a turning point
>> Alex Clark in the media spin. A Judeo-Christian pastor
goes after me. Okay, this is going to be about her.
problems with that evangelical pastor. I don't know. Are we going
to get more texts here? Cuz I don't think we're getting more
like logs. So, the only log she posted was one where Charlie
said apparently this is it. This is the only logs we got posted.
Okay. So, Charlie says, "Oh, I'm thinking about inviting Candace
now. Other than that, we got no new evidence. It's just her over
one screenshot." Okay. All right. I get Fair enough, Candace.
Okay. Fair enough. All right.
From here, where are we going? I think we're going to go to the
Asmin gold video people linked. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold
on. What is this
>> Why? Oh, okay. Hold on. We do some like Asthma slop
react here. I think so. I think we do a little bit of this. We'll
do this guy and then maybe we'll go to court docs or something.
I don't know. We'll see. We'll see. Okay. Uh, Idiocracy is a
not a comedy. It's a documentary. Asenold reacts.
It's a fun little side clip. Okay. out of nowhere. >> But
you might be surprised to learn that the movie's eventual popularity
was actually never intended from the start. For those of you
who have seen it, you can probably skip ahead a few minutes right
now because you already know the plot obviously, but if you haven't
seen the film before, it's effectively a scathing critique of
American corporatism. The main character, Joe Bowers, and a lady
of the night, if you will, named Rita, become the subjects of
an army experiment, cryogenic freezing in this case. But instead
of one year, they get frozen for hundreds. After finally waking
up in 255, I think it is, they re-enter the modern world and
they find out that everyone around them is basically brain dead.
Basic infrastructure is now falling apart. Everyone drinks Brondo
instead of water, which is like a play on Gatorade >> The
film is basically a never- ending string of jokes about >> it's
got electrolytes, okay? It's got what plants crave. Everyone
has become an idiot. Which leaves the two main characters who
are decidedly average back in the time that they come from >> the
most intelligent people on all of planet Earth. >> That's
right. >> Simply because of basic logic, mental.
>> Okay. I
>> thank God. Welcome to Costco. I love
>> And deductive reasoning. It's honestly prophetic in
a sense when it comes to the concept of corporate advertising
at least. People buy everything that they want from a city-sized
Costco. >> I don't know if I can do this. Evil Johnny Bravo.
I thought about doing
I'm I'm terrified of doing this. I feel like I'm going to lose
I feel like I'm going to lose brain cells. Okay. >> Facility
where they're greeted by someone who says, "Welcome to Costco.
I love you." There it is. >> They get treated in the hospital
by plugging little sensors into their mouth and their act and
their ear as well with a drooling human operator who doesn't
even really know what's happening as the machine spits out a
diagnosis for them. >> Right. Of course. >> And all
over the place everywhere you see a kind of logical extreme in
the world of attention advertising which now >> Okay, I
do like the movie.
>> I might have to go in a different direction. We'll see.
The point is more about Asmin Gold's take on the meta analysis.
Yeah, I I know.
But
okay, hold on. Let's let's skip forward. Skip forward past >> a
function of birth rates. >> We'll uh we'll skip forward
past the start of the >> as the more affluent portions
of society struggle with choices about when or why or even if
they ever want to have a child, those around them, the idiots,
are breeding like rabbits. Yep. >> The film asserts that
over hundreds of years, less intelligent people having much more
offspring as a kind of twisted evolutionary inversion overwhelms
the entire population. Therefore, dumbing everyone down to a
level where they can't even hardly think for themselves. >> That's
like real life as a >> how I mean this is never gonna happen,
right? I mean, there's no way this could >> I believe I
believe Andrew Wilson argues this is happening and why like Christian
nationalism will win in America. >> Commentary on predatory
capitalism is political ideology. Large corporations happily
step in to monetize that issue, creating a sort of death spiral
of sorts, ultimately resulting in people getting dumber and dumber
and dumber with each passing generation because none of them
are ever forced to think for themselves. It's a Hold on. Apparently,
I missed the best part of Candace Owen's video. Okay, my bad.
I missed the best part. I didn't mean to miss it. Okay, I didn't
mean to miss it. I have to pull it up. Hold on. If I
found
Breit's
I will find who killed Charlie Kirk.
>> Wow,
that is Yeah. Yeah, that's uh that's maybe the best clip of all
time. I
I want to attack that on like a factual basis and say but you
didn't find it
but it's just so absurd. Okay. >> If I
found
Reje,
I will find who killed Charlie Kirk. If >> you're not allowed
to ask those
found
Breit.
>> Yeah, this this came through to my uh my phone or my
sorry, my watch. I follow that person on Twitter, that Shadow
of Ezra account. I follow that account. That's how I got it.
That's how I was watching that that quickly. >> Fun movie.
I do like it. Which again has >> I really hope he brings
up the fact that computer literacy is going down because computers
are so good and people no longer have to diagnose their own problems
with them. >> I really hope parallels now, but setting
aside the obvious and more surface level ones like teenagers
speaking with broken grammatically absurd slang or >> they
only do that because it's funny and uh because like rappers or
people in like music do that. Uh I think in a lot of cases that's
the real reason. It's the same as like, you know, we used to
say like ski or something like that. Busing like I feel like
that's like just kind of like kid slang.
>> Sorry. Sorry. Hey, I uh I I have to throw up a tweet
on that one. Gay
>> number three news podcaster in America. >> Concept
invading deeper and deeper into we did the same stuff. >> I
want to make the argument that the cause of those issues is not
a function of birth rates or genetics. It's a function of the
tools that we're making which supplant our own critical thinking.
Let's get to it. I want to take a minute here. >> I just
want to show you guys something.
>> wait a video. What did I call that >> Um, I made
a video about this recently
>> and I wonder if he watched it
because I for I forgot what the name of the video >> and
go on a bit of a tangent, I guess, because lately it feels like
there's an
>> I have a feeling that it's entirely possible that Asmin
Gold is the basis for his inspiration for this video.
Consensus news seems to be going rapidly downhill. Maybe that's
because way too many people get their information from social
media posts where the first word is breaking in all caps because
it's just engagement farming. Let's >> Who would do that?
Wait, who would do that? Who would tweet with like breaking like
that?
>> It's also because media standards in general have gone
wildly downhill. As a solution to that, I deliberately work with
a platform called Ground News, which is today's video sponsor
as well. Because
I do spell checkers. >> I do love that Asmin watches the
whole video. Okay, the whole app >> checkers are ubiquitous
now. Everyone has them at practically every single level of education
and work because they're embedded directly into our devices.
Which means at a certain level after a child has learned basic
grammar and spelling techniques in school, they'll begin using
spellchecking software nearly 100% of the time in their day-to-day
lives. >> See, I was an early adopter of being stupid at
spelling. I I I I was always garbage at spelling. Even whenever
I was a kid and we didn't have spellch >> Where does the
money come from that they keep paying people there? They sponsor
every video on YouTube now. They're literally every video on
YouTube is sponsored by ground news. >> I was still trash
at it.
>> Spell check. You'll learn eventually. >> What if
I told you it doesn't just help us, it also stagnates. According
to the International Journal of Social Sciences and Educational
Studies regarding EFL students learn English as a foreign language,
quote, "With the advent of technology, writing devices are now
equipped with autocorrection features that automatically corrects
or generates a list of potential words to the author. This has
made the task apparently easier. However, based on the cognitive
load theory, when there is not enough effort and time given to
complete a learning task, the chances to learn effectively reduce."
End quote. Further down, quote again, "Having taken the affforementioned
reasons and challenges into account, the primary aim of the present
research is to investigate the effects of autocorrection features
on spelling competence among EFL learners. >> English is
a first language." >> This may seem like nothing. I get
it. But if you go all the way down to the results on page 108,
you find this quote, "The control group, participants who handwrote
writing tasks and assignments, performed enormously better at
reducing the number of misspelling words in their tasks in comparison
to the experimental group who typed written tasks." End quote.
Lastly, from the conclusion obviously,
students who are deeply immersed in using programs with auto
spellch checker features don't hone spelling competence as students
who depend on handwriting due to the fact that there is more
effort involved in handwriting that makes the learning more sustained.
End quote. >> Now, for me personally, what I did is that
I just did handwriting and I spelled everything wrong. Of course,
that is just one study that does very clearly seem to indicate
that handwriting and putting in more effort will make you process
learning better and typing with a spell checker does not help
you learn when it comes to English as a foreign language. But
it is echoed elsewhere, right? The general premise from university
technology mara a study called the influence of spell checkers
on students ability to generate repairs of spelling errors in
the conclusion paragraph page 10. Quote, "This research suggested
that spell checkers have little to no effect."
>> Sorry. Uh, Asigold decided to follow up. Okay, he follows
up. Asig Golds take 85% removing 85% of the people, okay, from
the from the voting population. It's making waves on Reddit apparently.
But he says on second thought, maybe it should be 90%. Okay,
doubles down. He doubles down. He's doubling down. Amazing. He
really wants to eat the bugs. That's like that's his goal. Okay,
he's actually a globalist pl uh globalist plant. He's going to
get all of these people to agree to give up their right to vote
and then everyone eats the bugs >> whatsoever on students
spelling errors on the cognitive level. It did not help repair
the errors and the corrections are not internalized,
thus allowing learners to repeat the same end quote.
We're starting small, but the idea of ubiquitous spellchecking
software seems to indicate a stand.
>> Yeah, I listen, it's not quite as good as uh I thought
it would be. the evil Johnny Bravo. But it's it's all right.
It's fine.
Listen, we got uh we got a bunch of other stuff we're going to
do tonight because I was kind of expecting that to go somewhere.
I'm going to take a look at this as well. Listen, I told all
the fitness bros in the Discord, I'd take a look at Dr. Mike.
Okay,
so I'll take a look at Dr. Mike. If you guys haven't heard, apparently
Dr. Mike Israel
had his PhD exposed as like a sham. Okay, total sham.
the Dr. Mike Discord people are raid like in my Discord or just
all over the place. These people all hate Dr. Mike. They don't
like him. Okay, so yeah, apparently he um apparently he faked
his PhD or something. Jesus. Let's check it >> There are
people who >> This gets better day by day. Has Dr. Mike
responded to it? >> Let their work speak for them. And
then there are people who shout so loudly about how brilliant
they are, you start to wonder what they're trying to drown out.
Oh god. Nobody told me that this person was like Australian or
some [__] Oh [__]
Seriously? Wait, what is this? What is this? >> And um
also
>> what is this? As says if Destiny goes down, he wants
to see the Destiny files. Please, I'm begging, praying. Let us
know. Think about how many videos that's going to be. If my friends
were on the list, I want it released even more because I don't
want to be friends with >> So, we've been talking a lot
about the Epstein list. What about the Destiny list? Do you remember
this? Whenever Destiny said, "Bro, if I need to go on the offender
list, I'm taking like 20 other streamers with me." Okay, lol.
W
release, release every name. Please, please, please. I am begging,
praying.
As Asminagold is the only guy, okay, other than me, but Asigold
is the only other influencer who sits here and is like, I never
leave my house. Yes, release the names. I can't be on the
I can't I literally I I cannot be on the list. Yeah, Teone's
probably [__] There's a good chance Tees Oh, wait.
Hold on. That's a different point you're making, Cherry. No,
I want it released even more. I don't want to be friends with
Saers. Well, isn't that an interesting comment? I don't want
to be friends with Saers. Have we gotten Tech's reaction to this?
Techie Tech, where you at? You don't want to be friends?
Asmin's calling you out, buddy. Calling you out directly. >> Hoping
on my knees.
Let us know. I want to know it. I want to know because think
about how many videos that's going to be for me.
Please do it. When are you going to do it? Many such cases. Yeah.
What the [__] He said that. No, I I What a weird
thing to say. Uh I don't What an odd thing to say. What a what
an odd thing to say. Know who's going to be on the list? Like
anybody? Well, you guys know here's the here's the truth, right?
You guys know I don't deal with stuff like that, right? You know,
I don't I,
you know, I'm an edgy guy. I, you know, love, uh, you know, runchy
humor and stuff like that. But when things approach real life
and its interactions with human beings and people are are hurt
and there's actual victims to things, then my mindset begins
to change, right? Then I start thinking about things differently.
And at least 5 years have gone to Exactly. And uh, yeah, I think
you're safe. I mean, well, it's hard. Yeah, it's kind of the
thing for me, right? I mean, and I've got What if all What if
your friends were on the list? If my friends were on this list
that Destiny has, I would say that I want it released even more
because I don't want to be friends with people that are assalters
and abusers. Wow.
And yet, okay. And yet, and yet, and yet. My goodness. All right.